cinq semaines pour devenir soldat à
dorington dans le sud de l'Angleterre
CESU craignait ont troqué leurs
vêtements civils pour enfiler l'uniforme
leur patrie est attaquée ils ont donc
décidé de prendre les armes à leur tour
pour prêter main forte à leur armée
de l'invasion
je ne pouvais plus continuer comme ça je
ne pouvais plus vivre ma vie
formation tactique médicale et même
psychologique les britanniques tentent
de brasser large lors de ces 5 semaines
d'entraînement intensif le droit de la
guerre aussi est enseigné
les deux compétences les plus
importantes que nous devons leur
enseigner pendant cette formation sont
comment survivre sur un champ de
bataille et comment
rapprochés et le maniement des armes la
guerre urbaines la guerre des tranchées
les premiers secours sur le champ de
bataille et l'importance du droit des
conflits
les preuves du feu approche désormais
pour ses anciens civils et leur de
vérité avec les Britanniques assurent
avoir modifié leur formation pour lui
donner un aspect plus offensif et
permettre aux Ukrainiens non seulement
de se défendre mais aussi de regagner du
terrain de quoi espère-t-il pour suivre
la contre-offensive réussie menée depuis
plusieurs semaines